- YES.
- FLOWN HERE
FOR THE JOB INTERVIEW.
- YOU'VE GOT THREE BOYS,
AND YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A NANNY.
- UH-HUH.
- AND I'M A NANNY,
AND HERE I AM.
- YEAH, WE REMEMBER.
- I KNOW.
SO I JUST...
- LITTLE DID YOU KNOW
THAT YOU WOULD BE PRANKED
WITH TOO MUCH TUNA.
SO TELL US ABOUT YOURSELF.
- UM, WELL, I'VE BEEN WORKING
FOR TEN YEARS.
- OH-HO-HO.
WHAT IS THIS?
WHAT DID YOU ORDER?
- WHAT HAS BEEN PLACED
IN FRONT OF YOU?
- WHAT DID YOU DO?
- OH.
- I'M SORRY.
I DON'T--
- YOU'VE BEEN PRANKED.
- LOOK AT THAT.
- YEP.
- NOW, WOULDN'T YOU SAY
THAT THAT IS...?
- SO THEY--THEY'RE NOT COMING,
THE CHILDREN?
- WHO?
- THE KIDS.
- WHAT KIDS?
OH, THE FAKE AD.
NO, THERE'S NO KIDS.
- NO KIDS.
- NO.
- THERE'S ONE BABY HERE.
- THAT GUY RIGHT THERE.
- I DON'T EVEN LIKE TUNA,
AND YOU MADE ME FLY
ALL THE WAY OVER HERE
FROM LONDON.
- WHY DIDN'T YOU TAKE THE BOAT?
- YEAH.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GONNA TAKE
A LINER.
- SO THERE'S NO JOB,
AND THERE'S NO CHILDREN AND--
- MAY I ASK YOU
A QUESTION?
AND I DON'T--I DON'T MEAN
TO BE RUDE.
DO YOU HAVE
[bleep] MEMENTO DISEASE?
'CAUSE EVERY TWO MINUTES--
"IS THERE A JOB?
IS THERE KIDS?"
THERE'S NO KIDS.
THERE'S NO JOB.
THERE'S TOO MUCH TUNA.
YOU'RE ON A PRANK SHOW.
- RIGHT.
- WOULD YOU SIGN A RELEASE?